hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game from round four of the
2013 candidates tournament
it's Magnus Carlsen versus Alexander
Greece - now this game is a really a
positional masterpiece and I'm sure
you're all going to enjoy this one
but with before we get to the game we do
have a couple of photos to enjoy as well
so here we have a nice close-up of
Greece chick from the side here we have
also a nice close-up of Magnus cross and
looking over a grief shoulder here we
have also a very nice photo of of grief
cook and if you look at him it's if you
didn't see the the pieces on the bottom
of the photo it almost seems like he's
you know placing placing chips while
playing while playing poker here we have
also a nice close-up of Carlsen and if
you remember my coverage of the 2018
candidates tournament
we always had a photo of Greece chook
taking a stroll you know checking out
some other players games and it was no
different in 2013 as you see so I hope
you enjoyed that now let's let's check
out the game Carson has the white pieces
and he opens with E for now we have e5
and Knight to f3 knight c6 and Bishop to
b5 Duru Lopez Knight to f6 Grigio goes
for for the Berlin defense we have d3
and Bishop to c5 c3 now we have castles
cause and castles and the d6 h3 and here
comes a move that people criticize after
this game back should consider Bishop to
d7 here just you know wait waiting to
see where White will go in the game
Grichuk played 86 and d6 followed by a6
is not considered all that great it's
not it's not like it's a mistake or
anything but it's or maybe they just set
it because because of what happened but
it's very interesting how Carson takes
advantage of the double points in this
in this position so Carson played Bishop
captures we have B captures and now you
see it's it would be better if the pond
was not on a6 at this kind of
prevents the development of this bishop
but okay rook to you one by Carlsen rook
to e8 and now Knight B to d2
we have d5e characters on d5 you have to
capture with the Queen you can't handle
because the d5 point is hanging both the
knight and the rook are attacking it so
we have to play Queen captures on d5
we have Knight to b3 attacking the
bishop and here again a very interesting
decision by Greece choke you you want to
go something like Bush of 287 here you
can also decide to give up the bishop
pair simply start developing your pieces
of Bishop to f5 but agrees to plays a
very interesting move Bishop to f8 and
this is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine but it's it's
very interesting how Carson plays
against this Bishop to f8 Crossan plays
c4 we have Queen to d6 and now Bishop to
e3 now you always have to consider what
happens after Bishop to c5 so preventing
this we have Knight to d7 also planning
f5 d 4 by Carlsen and now F or you could
also exchange in the center with ich
after son before Bishop captures and
after captures captures c5 Queen to b4
attacking the rook on a 8 and after
black moves the rook Bishop to c3 you
didn't really achieve anything with
black here now the bishop on c3 is I
think that g7 pawn also guarding the B
to pawn so the knight can move the Queen
is centralized very nicely and when drew
comes into the game White's pieces are
all developed very nicely so instead and
the black would still have the doubled
pawns so instead he 4x3 shook he
prepares f5 and then he will start his
attack on the King side night after d2
by Carson and now a 5 preparing a for
Carson doesn't know I would he pushes a
for himself and here is a moment where a
Carlsen thought that Greece's next move
was kind of a mistake
Queen to g6 would be an idea here Queen
to g6 Knight to f6 would follow the
invisible can threaten all sorts of
ideas it would be an interesting move
but here British should immediately went
for f5 so definitely preparing f4 we
have
five by Carlson and this is the move
where where you really have to enjoy the
position so f4 is definitely a threat
trapping the bishop but what do you do
here is white there are there are there
are a lot of ideas here but across and
plays a move that too was considered to
be completely an anti positional he
plays c5 and c5 what it does of course
first it it prevents black from pushing
it for you you have to react your queen
is under attack but you also create a
very nice square on d5 for black's
knight so why would you do this
the reason is now those those BB pawns
on the Queen side are terrible and
they're you know they're fixed and
another thing it does this e5 point
really restricts this Bishop on f8 so
it's very nice by playing this move you
do allow this knight to come to d5 but
Carlson realizes that this will be much
less important than the useless bishop
on f8 so Queen to g6 and another move
Carson doesn't really enjoy across and
thought that Queen to e6 was much better
because you don't want to allow this
Knights to come to c4 but okay Queen to
g6 now Knight to c4 was played a knife
comes to f6 and now Bishop to f4 and
here okay Knight to d5 as Carson did
push c5 he allowed this knight to come
to d5 we have Queen to d2 and now as you
can see the a5 one is attacked three
times by the Queen and by both nights so
you have to decide what to do here here
there is an insertion three six was
played in the game but I will show just
the one variation because it's really
interesting for example Knight captures
Queen captures and after this let's say
Bishop to e6 you attack the undefended
night and here is the question I have
for you I feel free to pause the video
here and try to figure out well that
only if you want it's it's really a hard
question so if you're really up to it
then then feel free to do it do you
capture can you capture d a5 pawn and if
so which Knight captures the pawn so
it's it's a nice nice puzzle for you to
Anna
if you if you you know if you're really
up to it because it's really not easy
but I will show it as it's very
interesting so for those of you who
found it you are you're a brilliant
player and for those of you who would
would still like to see what happens
night B captures an a5 is the only is
the only correct idea if you found this
then that's perfectly fine but the real
problem is for you to realize why night
see captures on a5 is a problem well
this is a problem because now as you can
see the both nights are defending each
other and now comes Queen to f7 so two
Queen and the bishop are now attacking
the knight here of course you can't move
the knight because you lose the a5 night
after Y defense this rookie three now
comes Luke to b8 again attacking the
knight on b3 three times you have to
defend it and now comes Bishop to d5
regarding that c6 pawn and now what do
you play here as white as you can see
white didn't really lose anything in a
material way so white is still a point
but white doesn't really have a move all
of whites pieces are stuck guarding the
b3 night
so this is this is a pretty wild wild
position and it's a pretty bad position
for white because white can't really
make a move white can make a couple of
useless moves and after then it's all
black now black black is the one that
can make up a plan for example g6 Bishop
here he can move h5 now King can come
into play
I prepared Bishop to h6 and white really
doesn't have much to do here you have to
prevent this so you can go to g3
then Bishop to h6 traps your queen so
you'd have to go rook to h3 and then
still a bishop here Queen moves and then
f4 and then your pieces are still stuck
guarding the f3 the b3 night and now
your queen is stuck there on h2 this is
I mean this is just terrible for white
but it's very interesting in this
position after this Bishop to e6 you
know this is completely fine and if you
play Knight captures then you can
completely throw the game with white
so very interesting but okay after Queen
to d2 Grisha played Bishop to e6 and
it's very interesting this has only
moved 21 and he only has four minutes on
the clock
so I mean Grisha kisses the world blitz
champion but still he a playing
classical game with only four minutes on
the clock and move 21 that's I mean
certainly he ran into some heavy
preparation and he really had to figure
out how to deal with this cousins anti
positional c5 move but now he still has
to play 19 more moves to reach down
control with only four minutes on the
clock and that's you know without making
any mistakes that would be incredible so
here across some place might be
characters on a5 grabbing the pawn we
have rook to b8 and now Knight to e5
also a very interesting idea could could
cross and capture on c6 what happens
here well if he captures Knight captures
on c6 then you get Knight captures on f4
Queen captures and Bishop captures on c4
Knight captures rook can be eight rook
captures and now Queen captures pawn on
c7 rook captures pawn and b2 and here
Carlson district would have two bishops
for a rook but a cross his position is
still better he has three passed pawns
and black blacks attack doesn't doesn't
really doesn't really work so that'd be
that that still be better for Carlsen
but he decided not to go into this he
played nice to e5 he attacked the Queen
Queen to f6 and now Bishop to h2 he
doesn't allow the knight to capture the
bishop on f4 rock to rock to rock to fa5
capturing the night and now Queen
captures an a5 Grigios now sacrifices
the exchange so he can play rook capture
some b2 so there are there are some
threats to the position of course this
rook is now a nicely placed on the
second rekt or rank after the Queen
comes to the G filed and ideas like III
will be an option but you'll see how
this is very nicely taken care of rook a
to be one calls and offers a trade rook
to a to English of course declines and
here we have
Queen to a6 again guerrilla troops just
sacrifice the exchange of course you
don't want to Allah play something like
knife captures in c6 I grab a
meaningless pawn because now you would
definitely give black counter play via
III and after F captures Queen to g6 is
coming now black is already threatening
checkmate
then ideas like f4 Bishop h3 are in the
air so you don't want to allow this for
a for no reason you're you're already up
in material no reason to grab more
meaningless material so across some
place ace Queen a6 and it's it's
interesting how Queen to a6 is actually
a beautiful defense against pawn to e3
and and you'll see cousin goes Queen to
a six-issue display III and now Causton
does capture it pawn captures we have
Queen to g5 now Grichuk threatens
checkmate on g2 and now we have worked
we to so very nice now Queen from a6 is
guarding the rockin e2 Knight captures
on e3 now again threatening that the
g-tube on by the knight qui and and the
Queen and now nice to f3 first attacking
the Queen Queen to g6 and now rook
captures on a to Bishop captures on a -
and now rook the b2 again attacking the
bishop Bishop to c4
attacking Carlson's Queen and I'll
simply Queen to a5 preparing to bring
the Queen back into the defense Bishop
to d5 we have Queen t1 and now at four
Bishop captures on f4 and night to see
two attacking the Queen
you don't really gain anything my Bishop
captures okay the point is spin but
simply Queen captures on e3 and Carson
is still up the exchange this Bishop is
still out of the game that c5 pawn
although it looks weird it's actually
beautiful completely locking this Bishop
out of the game and fixing those pawns
here and even if the pieces and the
Queen's are exchange constants a pawn is
simply marching up to victory so here
after Bishop captures on f4 Knights the
c2 and here we have Queen to f2 Bishop
captures on f3 and here Carlsen can
actually capture this Bishop now and
allow after Queen captures
Knight captures attacking the Queen and
now after Queen - f - it seems like
Bishop captures on c5 is excellent for
black because you have all of these nice
discoveries but actually Bishop to e3
stops all of blacks counterplay and
white is completely winning here at once
again
but after Bishop captures an f3 across
and simply played rook captures on c2
and it was in this position that
Alexander II should resigned the game so
yeah it's very interesting and it's
something you will not see very often in
chess especially in such high level
chess in a candidates tournament that
one player will be here after Queen to
d2 by Carlsen already after Bishop to e6
down to 4 minutes on the clock and it's
a classical game you know you are
playing this tournament to challenge the
world champion for the title of roaches
champion so I mean a very interesting
game as groups games are always
extremely interesting but that's that's
some gambit but ok he did have to figure
out a lot of a lot of great ideas to the
break even from the position so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I do hope you enjoy the photos and
tomorrow you will only get one video
because I'm not in my hometown now we'll
be visiting true gear 4 for a short
blitz tournament tomorrow it will be a
team event so probably gonna just make
one video and and publish it tomorrow so
you can enjoy it it will be another game
from round 4 of the other 2013
candidates but yeah I do hope you
enjoyed this game I do hope you enjoyed
the photos as well there is a lot of
useful information in the description
below as such as more photos from round
4 and a very very nice article by Peter
Dodgers from round 4 and yeah as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
I think about for watching and of course
the oranges are all in the basket thank
you all and see you soon